So you might remember that a couple of weeks
ago, Michael Bloomberg ran these fat pick
ads of Donald Trump where it was an ad about
Trump's golfing where Michael Bloomberg said
something along the lines of, you know, the
only thing I would hire Trump, or I wouldn't
even hire Trump to run a golf course, something
like that.
But the visuals during that short ad were
these very, very unappealing pictures of Donald
Trump in a very light colored golf uniform
where he looks very heavy and Trump likely
is clinically obese as as many of you know.
And Trump was immediately just completely
triggered by Mike Bloomberg repeatedly tweeting
about Minnie Mike when that happened two weeks
ago.
Very, very much paying attention to what Michael
Bloomberg is doing and triggered by it.
And Trump actually came up with a pretty funny
line in response to those ads where he said
that Mike Bloomberg, Minnie Mike is negotiating
being allowed to stand on a box if he makes
it into the debates, which is really funny.
I mean, I think that Donald Trump's tweeting
could not be less presidential and embarrassing
to the country, but every once in awhile he
comes up with something funny like Bloomberg
is trying to negotiate, being allowed to stand
on a box.
And um, Michael Bloomberg has continued to
focus his ads on, uh, attacking Donald Trump
in a way that triggers Trump.
And it's working.
Trump tweeting more attacks on Bloomberg over
the last day, tweeting about Michael Bloomberg's
height.
Quote many.
Mike is a five foot, four inch massive dead
energy who does not want to be on the debate
stage with these professional politicians.
No boxes please.
He hates crazy Bernie and will with enough
money possibly stop him.
Bernie's people will go nuts.
Now Bloomberg is actually five foot eight.
That's a very respectable height, particularly
if you look at my driver's license, uh, not
five, four, but in all seriousness, attacking
a candidates height.
That's where Donald Trump has been relegated
to at this point.
Why do you think Trump is so easily triggered
and flabbergasted by what Michael Bloomberg
does?
Is it that Bloomberg is just so much richer
than Trump and from hates.
That is it that Bloomberg was able to express
his disdain for minorities in that unearth
audio in a much more eloquent sounding way
than Donald Trump has talked about.
You know, rapists and criminals from Mexico
or whatever.
I don't know what it is, but Bloomberg is
triggering Trump.
Trump going on to tweet along with a Photoshop
picture of Bloomberg's head on what seems
like a little kid's body.
This is the president of the United States
folks saying quote many Mike Bloomberg is
a loser who has money but can't debate and
has zero presence.
You will see he reminds me of a tiny version
of Jeb low energy Bush, but Jeb has more political
skill and has treated the black community
capital B for black, much better than many
capital M for many.
I shouldn't like this so much, but this is
like a guilty pleasure.
Trump's tweets about mini Mike Bloomberg and
the clear rage and disdain that he has for
Bloomberg are just delightful.
So let me know what you think.
Is Trump being triggered because Bloomberg
has more money because Bloomberg made his
money with the Bloomberg terminal instead
of inheriting it from his dad.
Is it that Bloomberg hasn't gone bankrupt
multiple times at the, uh, in his businesses
the way Donald Trump has?
I am not a Bloomberg supporter, as you all
know, but I find Bloomberg's rise in the polls
absolutely fascinating.
And I find the degree and ease with which
Bloomberg is able to trigger Donald Trump
and the way that it's playing out.
Absolutely.
And completely hilarious.
Let me know what you think.
I'm on Twitter at D Pacman.
Why is Trump so triggered by Bloomberg?
And then later in the show, I am going to
address this issue of, is Bloomberg an oligarch?
What does that term mean and is it a relevant
term in the United States relative to other
countries?
Um, there was a big dustup on MSN, I think
it was on MSNBC.
Maybe it was CNN.
Who knows.
I don't watch any of them about the term oligarch
being applied to Michael Bloomberg.
Uh, recently.
We will talk about that in audience questions.
Your calls are upcoming, and of course, I
want to hear from you on Twitter at D Pacman.
Follow me there and let me know what you think
about Trump's trigger ability
at the
hands
of Michael Bloomberg,